so
around the world there are over 50
million people fleeing hunger
war and persecution that's more refugees
than at any time since the end of the
second world war
many of those who make it to germany are
turned away overwhelmed by red tape
or repatriated by the authorities
the church of the holy cross in berlin
offers them hope helps overcome the
language barriers
and in desperate cases gives them asylum
in the church
the legal framework for church asylum
has changed
dramatically in the past 20 or 30 years
but the reasons have stayed the same
severe humanitarian crises
psychological and other illnesses or the
physical dangers of returning to the
refugees country of origin
but it's simply unacceptable for germany
to say that they all have to go back to
italy because that's where they entered
the european union
so that's given rise to resistance and
criticism
and that's why there are more cases of
church asylum
pastor jurgen klopp has been helping
refugees for the past 30 years
here he's chairing a discussion between
refugees and politicians in berlin's
church of the holy cross
i believe there are some people here who
have something to say on that subject
i say no the agreement you can stay in
berlin
the refugees representatives want a just
consideration of their asylum
applications
and say if they were allowed to work
they would make a contribution to german
society
i think that proves what we would lose
if we were not able to keep these people
in our city
italy is the first port of call for many
refugees heading for germany
but eu law says they can only apply for
asylum
in the first eu country they reach
together with george we have no power
we have power so
church please we need your support more
than anyone most of these refugees are
muslims
their plight touches the hearts of the
christian congregation and they are
moved to help
the groning foundation the concept of
church asylum
is based on certain convictions which in
my case
come from the christian faith
but it's also a very human response to
ask yourself
what you can do to help when you see
people around you
in a desperate situation
the fact that in my case i have focused
on refugees
was not planned it simply developed out
of the direction that my life took
and his wife live in the former
caretaker's house on the edge of a
cemetery
he became pastor of the church of the
holy cross in the late 1970s
and got involved in social work
and after i finished school i had to
think about what i wanted to study
one day he asked me if i'd like to study
theology
well of course my faith was important to
me i already had an idea of what it
meant to me
its importance in my life and what it
could mean in relating to other people
i wanted to provide help for people who
needed help
is now retired but he's still very
active
just a few meters from his front door
lies the grave of chamal altoon
the young turk's death was the trigger
for kwan's commitment
to the victims of persecution
jamal who's buried here was a young man
from turkey
he sought refuge in germany refuge from
persecution
jamal altoon fled from the military
dictatorship in his country
he was a democracy activist and the
military hunter that seized power and
ankara in 1980
viewed him as a traitor there is no
doubt that altoon was a political
refugee
but the berlin authorities locked him up
like a dangerous criminal
for 13 months in solitary confinement
some people approached our parish and
asked if they could use our premises to
stage a hunger strike to protest against
this young man's detention
it was in the spring of 1983 that was
when we started looking into the
situation of refugees and especially the
question of political asylum
but the story of jamal altoon ended
tragically
terrified that he would be deported to
turkey alton jumped from a window of the
courtroom during his hearing
and died immediately
thousands of sympathizers attended his
funeral
it was conducted jointly by an imam and
jurgen kvant
the death of jamal altoon was a turning
point in pastor kwan's life
is a reminder of what it means to be a
refugee
and to be buried in a foreign country
when their bodies are washed up on the
island of lampedusa
they're also buried in foreign soil
the first thing refugees need is shelter
hello pete are we at home how are you
jurgen kwan housed refugees and empty
administrative buildings at protestant
cemeteries
this is where pete lives he's from
cameroon where ethnic minorities are
marginalized oppressed
and persecuted and often jailed without
trial
pete was tortured and he was traumatized
when he arrived in germany
he's still frightened of his persecutors
and wants to remain anonymous
i should visit you because i got a
letter from christa
which she had written to the
centromere falter off right now and
there she uh she asked for help for you
that
that you can go there have you been
there
and and are you also pete is receiving
therapy in a center for victims of
torture
the church also organizes language
courses
i'm learning german i've been photo here
[ __ ] man he's learning quickly
at home he spoke several dialects
of course right you keep getting better
mankind
you can also see a happy child in the
picture okay
bye bye peach
although peter's learning german fast he
is often alone
he looks forward to the pastor's regular
visits
for him a pastor is someone to look up
to
but the reality is just the opposite i
should look up to him
he feels flattered that a person he
views as an authority has taken an
interest in his well-being
i hope that together we'll manage to
resolve his situation eventually
the church of the holy cross first
offered asylum to refugees
30 years ago shortly after jamal
altoon's death
political activists contacted pastorfund
and asked him to help a group of
palestinian refugees
the families had been living in berlin
for some time
now they were due to be deported to
war-torn lebanon
they included the hamudi family who the
pastor is now visiting
we hadn't actually planned to offer them
asylum in the church
but the first refugee families were
brought to the parish center
along with several mattresses
the activists rang the doorbell and said
these people urgently need shelter
otherwise they're going to be deported
i had no opportunity to verify the claim
i could either say
okay come inside or go away
i decided to let them in and that had
tremendous consequences
jurgen klopp has kept in touch with
those first asylum seekers he sheltered
in his church
my decision was momentous because it
introduced the first
church asylum in modern times without
actually knowing what was involved
it meant that for several weeks the
parish center was occupied by
three families with lots of children
with accommodation and legal advice
instead of being deported to a war zone
they were able to return to their berlin
apartment
and they're still in germany 30 years
later during their weeks of church
asylum
they forged friendships that have
endured over the years
and took everybody off in front of the
police
by stopping buses and saving refugees
from being deported
the pastor and his helpers drew public
attention
german society became more sensitive to
the plight of refugees
that was the beginning of asylum in the
church
and lots of parishes first in berlin and
then across the whole of west germany
joined the movement
they provided church asylum to prevent
refugees from being deported
to countries where their lives were
endangered
and among politicians and that
discussion is still continuing
the headquarters of asylum in the church
is at the church of the holy cross
pastor kwant was co-founder of the
association and until recently it's
chairman
the main focus is to provide independent
legal advice
the association is funded entirely with
donations
and almost all of the staff are
voluntary workers
applying for asylum in germany is
complicated
refugees are foreigners who don't know
the legal requirements or even how to
apply for asylum
jurgen kwan comes to the office
frequently to ask about the refugees
application status
and discuss the possibilities of
concrete assistance
they have permission to stay and are now
applying for citizenship
and speaking as a pastor and a
theologian
i would say that it's a tremendous
pastoral and human challenge
to bear the pain and give them hope and
courage
the current chairman of asylum and the
church pastor bernhard fricker
meets dede from nigeria who has been
living in germany as a so-called
tolerated refugee
now he's facing repatriation and fears
toleration status has been rescinded
because he was drug dealing
he went to jail and was then put on a
plane headed for nigeria
he would rather die than return home and
face torture so he took
tablets a doctor stopped his deportation
now he faces repatriation again
asylum in the church has made a film
about the nigerian's fate
i've lived in germany for 21 years
we had to shoot as a young soldier diddy
refused to shoot unarmed civilians
as a result a woman and her children
were shot by others
she took a few steps
the woman and the children were dead
because he refused to shoot diddy was
tortured and faced
death but he managed to escape his
situation was precarious
delhi never wanted to leave nigeria but
he had no choice
so he came to germany a country he
trusted
you can easily imagine how completely
disoriented
and helpless they are in a strange
environment
they're dependent on strangers
and the new world that they enter is
often bureaucratic
and restrictive
to find their feet is not just
incredibly difficult
for many it's impossible
to help people like diddy many more
parishes are needed
to provide asylum and assistance
jurgen kwan visits pastor dieter
schultzer in joachim's tal
a short distance from berlin
kwant explains the government's refugee
policy and emphasizes how important the
work of asylum in the church is
right now jordan iraq and turkey are
accepting hundreds of thousands of
syrian refugees
and
and we don't even allow the syrian
families already living here to take in
their refugee relatives
at their own expenses
the reason is that our politicians are
afraid that their approval ratings will
fall
back to
an increasing number of refugees are
being refused asylum in germany
many of them protest against the
unwelcoming policy
they occupy public places including
churches
jurgen klopp understands their anger and
fears that europe will isolate itself
even more that he says is no solution
the inner structure of an isolationist
society will
always become more restrictive because
refugees will continue to arrive
and you have to deal with that pressure
it's simply there
and this has an effect on society
i believe that everything we've slowly
built up in this society over nearly 60
years
since 1945 will be lost
certain democratic forms and a certain
culture
compassion and willingness to accept
responsibility for others
and much much more democracy itself will
suffer
jurgen klopp is making another trip to
joachim's tower
the church there has started helping
refugees
two men from somalia who fled their
country years ago
are due to be deported immediately
the association asylum in the church has
reviewed the men's situation
and sees no possibility other than
playing for time
the society's lawyers will fight for a
review of their applications
knows the two somalian refugees are at
least temporarily safe here
so we're here where do you come from
from somalia from somalia
and where have you been before
yeah yeah hassan has had a long journey
ukraine before arriving in germany he
was in austria
slovakia ukraine moscow
and ethiopia
seven places in three and a half years
may i ask you what have you done in
somalia uh
somalia what was your problem i was in
business man
businessman yeah okay and why did you
flee
already bought from five sharif's only
transgression was that he fell in love
with a woman from another village
they wanted to marry but neither his own
clan
or that of the bride would accept that
his relatives threatened to kill him
his only choice was to go to europe or
stay and be killed
and so he fled to holland where he lived
on the streets for seven years
now he wants to stay in germany
the two somalians met in a german
refugee camp
now they're being cared for by asylum in
the church
they were forced to flee their homeland
in haste her son left his wife
and children behind
full of children
his name is abdikafi
would you take your family from somalia
to germany
is it your your wish
indeed it's his fervent wish to be
reunited with his family
he's worried about his wife and five
children they keep in contact by email
and his wife sent him these pictures
his youngest
because he was unjustly accused of
spying for the enemy
he was condemned to death but managed to
escape from jail
foreign
the two refugees would not receive such
a warm welcome
everywhere in germany
i feel my life started now when i come
in germany before seven years
i was going down now i'm going up yeah
because i i hope so when you
when you hop something is good and when
you don't have
anything it's different so i feel is
hope
now
i think it's really great the way the
two of them sharif and hassan
have found their feet so quickly
i think it shows that church asylum also
helps to
integrate newcomers this success proves
it
foreign between
70 and 80 percent of all church asylums
end well
uh efforts or at least they create
opportunities for the refugees
maybe not a permanent situation but at
least a temporary opportunity
and i think that's a lot
the concept of church asylum is not
covered by german law
these christians simply act because they
see a desperate need
you